prince william offers an update on queen
elizabeth's beloved corgis well of
course we can't forget the corgis they
were her majesty's absolute favorite as
a newly titled prince of wells greets
the public someone asked about the
queen's canines
they're two very friendly
she grew up with corgis her father
george vi gifted her a corgi when she
was little and from then i think a love
affair was cemented because the the
queen kept corgis for her entire life
yeah over the years corgis became a
royal staple at buckingham palace even
showing up in her majesty's on-screen
portrayals
i brought some stew just in case i think
it's lamb we could always have that
killed no we'll be all right
stay
she was never without them trailing
behind her sort of yapping at anyone
that that dared to try and stroke them
they would only allow the queen to
stroke them in the wake of his mother's
death king charles iii smiled as he
greeted someone holding their little
corgi
so who's going to look after the corgis
well she has two um
sandy and mewak muic is named after one
of her favorite rivers in scotland and
um it's going to be the duke of york he
is going to take care of the corgis the
corgis have actually already been given
to prince andrew he spent a lot of time
with the queen in the in the last months
of her death and i think he was one of
the few who the corgis didn't try and
bite and um he he seemed to have a good
rapport with them so it was the queen's
wish that um sandy and muic went to
andrew well as well as her love of
corgis which is of course well known is
her love of horses the queen wasn't just
a wonderful equestrian a great horse
woman who actually rode well into her
90s and she was also a very professional
serious horse owner she had a keen
interest in horse racing and she owns
race horses so the master of the horse
john warren who
actually walked behind her procession as
she went to lay in stage will be the man
in charge of working out exactly what
happens now to the queen's horses i do
know that it was her majesty's wish that
that love of horses and racing is
continued through the next generation
camilla queen consort is also a big fan
of horse racing and she also owns a
racehorse with the prince of wales so i
think there's every chance that she will
inherit some of the queen's racehorses
possibly some of them will be sold but
in terms of that affiliation between
royals and racing which has really kept
the sport alive in britain i think
that's going to be very much down to
camilla to continue
[Music]